getting to become a superpower i guess i
would have to battery responses number
one yes in fact not only can India
become a superpower it is well on its
way to getting there and give them the
bait of its population given its
geopolitical situation given the
resources it has and given belatedly be
significant improvement it is starting
to see in its governance and given the
world we live in where it's difficult as
good ideas and it's difficult to
suppress the expectation of the
population and given it being a liberal
democracy in my mind it is absolutely
never also not only can India become a
superpower it will definitely become
possible the second point I would add is
becoming a superpower I think in the
future is going to mean very different
things that it has mentally most and in
some ways you can argue that this the
concept of a superpower is going to
become a little irrelevant because there
will be three four five perhaps economic
powers that will anchor the world and if
all of them are super powers then not
sure anyone has a superpower
thank you